madame monsieur bonsoir la qualité
d'abord sportif ce samedi avec la finale
dames à roland garros sur le court
central justine henin s'est emparé de la
victoire en deux sets clouant sur place
sa compatriote kim clijsters pourtant
tête de série numéro 2 une championne et
sous le regard bienveillant du roi des
belges justine a donné le meilleur
d'elle-même le royaume est à la fête
nathanaël de rincquesen alex horne de
kits le bonheur pour justine henin c'est
simple comme une victoire à roland
garros
cet après midi la jeune belge a ému aux
larmes
les spectateurs du central en allant
jusque dans les tribunes partager son
succès avec son mari puis en rendant
hommage à sa maman aujourd'hui disparu
je voudrais dédier cette victoire maman
qui veille sur moi depuis le paradis
j'espère fait c'est très fier de moi
maman passe à kim clijters pourtant 2e
joueuse mondiale justine henin se montre
la plus entreprenante
un coup à droite un coup à gauche kim la
flamande est dépassé dans les tribunes
lleyton hewitt son fiancé semble inquiet
il y a de quoi
justine la wallonne est en train de
réussir à s'en faut son adversaire est
aux abonnés absents
la première manche est expédié en 29
minutes 6 0
une arrivée je me sentais bien même dans
le premier set mais je n'ai jamais
trouvé le bon rythme qui a fait ma force
dans la deuxième manche
kim clijters 2 se montre guère plus
inspirés justine henin elle poursuit sa
démonstration
encouragé par son numéro un mondial de
fiancé kim clijters finit enfin par
montrer le bout de son nez
timidement juste ce qu'il faut pour
entretenir le suspense et faire durer le
plaisir
malheureusement pour elle cet après midi
justine henin avait réponse à tout
6 4 dans le deuxième set l' affaire est
entendue en 1h07
sous les yeux de non droit justine henin
s'offre un premier sacre à roland garros